now from super bowl 55
the chiefs and the bucks las vegas
sports books pretty busy getting ready
for their biggest weekend with all the
regular and prop bets of course
ron futrell joins us with the latest on
the super bowl
so here we go super bowl lv as in 55
in tampa bay kansas city chiefs against
the tampa bay buccaneers chiefs are
right around three to three and a half
point favorites
interesting point about this game is
these two teams have already played
in tampa bay kansas city won that game
by three
if the chiefs blow out you know they go
out to a 28-10 lead like they did
earlier
i don't know if the buccaneers really
will be able to match
that effort and come back open the
chiefs at three and a half it's down to
three as a lot of the big
early money has come in on the bucks
especially the money line
they are taking the underdog they're
taking the bucks right now
but we do anticipate a lot of kansas
city support
come next weekend now one area
sportsbooks are concerned with right now
the futures betting
a lot of bettors took tampa bay early at
big odds like
30-1 or 20-1 and the public could win
big with the bucks
our biggest loser is kansas city and our
second biggest loser is tampa bay so
we're hoping for a good amount of action
to come in on the game
between the two teams to balance out
some of that liability so the super bowl
in tampa bay this year it's the first
time
that a team has been able to play in
their home stadium
for the super bowl i'm ron futrell
reporting eight sports now